Bitte schön.
Ich fange an.
Guten Abend.
Setzen Sie sich bitte.
Oh danke.
Ich heiße Furkanbaran und bin auf diese Station als Dienstabende arztätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen diese Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Zuerst werde ich ein paar Argenbeine frage stellen.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Silke Hansen.
Können Sie Ihre Vorname und Nachname büchten?
Ja, der Vorname ist Silke.
S-I-L-K-E.
Silke.
Silke. Okay.
Und der Familienname ist Hansen.
H-A-N-S-E-N.
Silke Hansen.
Okay, Frau Hansen.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin jetzt 63 Jahre alt.
63. Und wann wurden Sie geboren?
Am 1. März 1960.
1960.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, so 74, 75 kg.
74 oder 75?
Ja, so, schwank ein bisschen.
Nein, ich kann das nicht sagen.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt?
Ja, Herr Dr. Schneider ist mein Hausarzt.
Dr. Schneider, ich kenne ihn sehr gut.
Das ist gut, ja.
Also, Frau Hansen, was hat Sie uns geführt?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe solche unglaublichen Kopfschmerzen.
Also, seit 3 Tagen habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich überhaupt nicht mehr normal denken kann.
Das sind solche heftigen Schmerzen.
Und ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich ein bisschen viel Stress hatte oder so.
Und ich habe gedacht, ich kann das nicht mehr aushalten.
Es ist so unangenehm.
Und ich kann auch nicht mehr richtig gucken.
Ich habe gedacht, ich kann das nicht mehr aushalten.
Ich kann auch nicht mehr richtig gucken.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass ich so Störungen vor den Augen habe.
Sie haben sehr störend genottet?
Ja, so das flimmert so vor meinen Augen.
Ich habe normalerweise auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Ich nehme eigentlich auch Medikamente.
Aber jetzt, ich messe ihn hin und wieder mal.
Heute war der richtig hoch.
Heute Morgen 180 zu 90.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, oh Mensch, jetzt musst du aber doch mal irgendwo hingehen.
Und mein Haus aus dem Augenblick ist nicht da.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt direkt in die Klinik gekommen.
Sie haben sehr gut gemerkt.
Und Sie haben Ihre Blutdruck gemessen.
Und 180.
Ja, heute Morgen war der so hoch.
180 zu 90.
Und können Sie das nicht mehr aushalten?
Ja, das klopft in den Schläfen.
Ich habe so klopfende Kopfschmerzen
und kochende Kopfschmerzen in den Schläfen.
Und das hört überhaupt nicht auf.
Und wo genau sind die Schläfenregionen vom Kopf?
Die beiden Seiten, oder?
Auf beiden Seiten.
Die beiden Seiten.
Und hatten Sie schon einmal diese Kopfschmerzen bekommen?
Ja, jeder hat mal Kopfschmerzen,
aber dass ich das so stark habe, kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Wenn 1 leichte und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen sind,
dann sind sie auf einer Skala von 1 und 10.
Dann sind sie auf einer Skala von 1 und 10.
Dann sind sie auf einer Skala von 1 und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Also abends sind die wirklich fast unerträglich.
Dann würde ich sagen, sind die bei 8.
Morgens geht es mir meistens ein bisschen besser.
Jetzt die Tage, da ist es vielleicht über der Hälfte,
so bei 6.
Aber ich wache eigentlich schon morgens mit Kopfschmerzen auf.
Und ich schlafe natürlich auch schlecht jetzt,
weil ich solchen Kopfdruck da habe.
Frau Hansen, wie verhalten sich die Schmerzen in Laufe der Zeit?
Und wie hat diese Schmerzen begonnen, also plötzlich oder langsam?
Ich würde sagen, die haben plötzlich angefangen
und gehen überhaupt nicht weg.
Und seit 3 Tagen sind sie da.
Die Schmerzen sind immer da, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Und ist Ihnen übel oder schwindelig?
Eigentlich nicht so richtig.
Also außer dieser Sehstörung,
dass ich nicht so richtig gucken kann.
Aber so richtig übel ich mir eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe mich auch nicht verstanden.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ja, also ich habe versucht, Ibuprofen zu nehmen.
Aber das hat eigentlich keine Besserung gebracht.
Und wenn ich mich hinlege und gar nichts tue,
dann ist es ein bisschen besser.
Ja, wenn ich ausruhe.
Aber wie gesagt, morgens ist es noch erträglich.
Aber gegen Abendwett ist es schon sehr unangenehm.
Und wie viele Milligramm haben Sie Ibuprofen eingenommen?
Das weiß ich gar nicht genau, was da drauf steht.
Ich glaube, das sind 600.
600, aber es hat Ihnen nicht geholfen?
Nein.
Und wann haben Sie Ihre Bruthochdruckmessung heute Morgen oder?
Heute Morgen war der so hoch.
Und der ist schon bekannt, ein bisschen erhöht.
Aber vor drei Tagen habe ich noch mal gemessen.
Da war der ein bisschen erhöht bei 150 zu 80.
Aber heute Morgen dann eben bei 180 zu 90.
Und da habe ich sogar gesagt, oh Mann, das ist aber auch wirklich...
Haben Sie da gegen irgendwelche Gemacht oder?
Ich nehme regelmäßig mein Ramipril.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig Ramipril.
Wie viele Milligramm Ramipril?
Was steht denn da drauf?
Ich glaube, das sind Ramipril 5, dann nehme ich eine morgens.
Nur morgens nehmen Sie einen.
Okay, und haben Sie Erbrochen?
Erbrochen?
Nein, habe ich nicht nehmen.
Ich habe mich so richtig schlecht nur diese wahnsinnigen Kopfschmerzen.
Und waren Sie ummächtig?
Umgosswimmen? Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Und...
Was kann ich noch fragen?
Haben Sie, sind Ihnen Lähmungen, Krippen oder Taubheitsgefühl
irgendwo aufgefallen?
Das einzige, was mir wirklich aufgefallen ist, ist diese Flimpern vor den Augen.
Aber sonst, also, dass die Hände kribbeln oder so, was habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Und haben Sie...
Ausgleichen, Gestörung oder...
Haben Sie gleichgewichtstörung?
Ja, gleichgewichtstörung bemerkt.
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt nicht so viel gearbeitet und dann bin ich nicht viel rumgelaufen.
Ich würde jetzt vielleicht heute nicht gerade auf eine Leiter steigen.
Aber direkt gleichgewichtstörung habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und können Sie diese Sehstörungen genau beschreiben?
Also, was meine Sie damit?
Ja, es klimmert vor den Augen, dass ich kein festes Bild habe.
Wie ein schlechtes Fernsehbild.
Okay, wie ein Blitz oder...
Nein, nein, nein.
Es ist klimmert.
Also, das Bild ist nicht richtig scharf.
Okay.
Nur auf einen Seite?
Nein, auf beiden Seiten.
Mit beiden Seiten.
Okay.
Und ich habe halt wahnsinnigen Durst.
Ich könnte die ganze Zeit trinken.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Also, Sie haben schon...
Sie haben eine Schlafstörung gern wegen der Schmerzen.
Ja, weil ich jetzt diese Schmerzen habe, kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
Normalerweise habe ich da eigentlich keine Probleme.
Ich meine, ich muss nachts manchmal auf die Toilette, aber...
Also, sonst eigentlich kein Problem.
Sie haben kein Problem bei Wasser lassen und mit Zutulgang?
Nein, also das läuft eigentlich alles ganz normal.
Ja.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ernähren Sie Sie Hausgewogen?
Na ja, was man so versucht, ja.
Ja, also ich koche halt für die ganze Familie
und da kocht man halt so regelmäßig.
Und ich denke schon, dass wir uns gut essen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie es bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen bei Lärm und Licht verstärkt hätten, oder?
Nein, eigentlich habe ich mehr so das Gefühl,
dass das so der Stress bei der Arbeit ist.
Dieses hektische und unter Zeitdruck arbeiten oder so,
dass ich dann, dass ich denke, ich kann nicht mehr die Schmerzen sind da.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht mehr.
Schürzen Sie in der Nacht?
Nein, ich nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Fibar?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber fieber ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe nur diese Wahnsinnkopfschmerzen.
Wahnsinnkopfschmerzen, okay.
Und Frau Hansen, leiden Sie an irgendwelche Vorherkrankungen
aus der Arterie-Hypothonie?
Ja, also man hat vor einigen Jahren so ein Diabetes festgestellt,
halt so ein Altersdiabetes, wie man so sagt.
Und...
Welche Tipp?
Bitte?
Welche Tipp, Tipp 1 oder 2?
Nein, diese Altersdiabetes, also Typ 2.
Und dann nehme ich halt mit von mir morgens und abends.
Wie viel Milligramm?
850.
850, okay.
Und gibt es noch etwas?
Nein, also vor zehn Jahren hatte ich mal eine geilen Blasenoperation.
Aber das ist alles lange vorbei und vergessen.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt?
Ja, bei dieser geilen Blasenoperation war ich stationär.
Ja, außer die Operation.
Jetzt wüsste ich nicht, bei der Geburt der Kinder war ich natürlich stationär, aber sonst nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie ganz genau.
Und sind Sie gegen Covid geimpft und Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, also ich glaube ich bin sehr vollständig geimpft gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten und gegen Covid natürlich auch.
Und wie viel mal gegen Covid?
3 mal.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit in Ausland?
Nein, im Ausland war ich nicht.
Ich war nie.
Und nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein, außer Ibuprofen, Ramipril, 5 Milligramm und mit mind. 650 Milligramm?
850.
Ach, 850.
Das sind die beiden Sachen, die ich regelmäßig nehme.
Und dann wie gesagt mal bei Schmerzen, Ibuprofen, aber in dem Fall hat es nicht geholfen.
Und haben Sie Allergien?
Ja, ich habe eine Penicillinallergie, die ist bekannt.
Wie reagieren Sie sich mit Penicillin?
Ja, ich kriege da so ein Hautausschlag und es rötet sich und, ja, seit ich das weiß, versuche ich das natürlich zu vermeiden.
Und das ist eigentlich nur einmal aufgetreten.
Und Frau Hansen, trauchst du?
Nein, geraucht habe ich noch nie.
Aber haben Sie vorher geraucht?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Überhaupt, mein Leben lang nicht geraucht.
Das war sehr gut.
Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Regelmäßig, wirklich nicht.
Ganz gelegentlich.
Ich trink mal am Wochenende oder wenn es mal ein Fest gibt oder wenn es eine Einladung gibt.
Da trinke ich schon mal ein Glas Wein oder auch mal ein Sommer ein Bier.
Oder mal Likör zum Kaffee, aber nein, regelmäßig wirklich nicht.
An der Wochenende trinken Sie?
Ja, also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, ich trinke an Wochenenden.
Selbst an Wochenenden trinke ich gelegentlich mal ein Glas Einflug.
Okay.
Und Frau Hansen, ich muss eine unangenehme Frage stellen.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das gehört zu einem vorständigen Anamnese, Aufnahmegeschichte.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert?
Drogen?
Ja.
Also die Versuchung war natürlich da in meiner Jugend, aber ich habe mich tatsächlich nie getraut.
Ich habe das nie probiert.
Was haben Sie probiert?
Ich habe es nie probiert.
Sie haben als Junge gesagt, aber?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, in der Jugend war die Versuchung groß.
Da gab es das viel so im Umfeld.
Aber ich konnte mich da immer fernhalten.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, in meinem Alter ist das nicht mehr so viel mit Sport.
Ich habe einen stressigen Beruf, aber am Wochenende fahre ich mal mit dem Fahrrad.
Im Sommer gehe ich auch mal schwimmen und im Urlaub gehen wir wandern.
Aber jetzt auch nicht mehr mit großen Ambitionen.
Sehr gut.
Und Frau Hansen, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe eine gewachsene Töchter.
Sind Ihr Töchter gesund?
Wir sind um Glück gesund, ja.
Okay.
Und wohnen Sie mit Ihrem Mann?
Ja, Mann, ich glaube.
Wir sind auch selbstständig, mein Mann.
Und wir haben eine eigene Tischlerei.
Und wir wohnen und wir leben und arbeiten zusammen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Wie gesagt, ich arbeite in der Tischlerei mit als Buchhalterin.
Buchhalterin, okay.
Okay.
Sind Ihr Eltern an Irgendwärsche vor Erkrankungen?
Frau Hansen?
Noch mal bitte.
Ja, ich bin ein Erkranker.
Mein Vater ist relativ früh gestorben.
Er hat in Bergwerke arbeitet.
Er hatte eine Staublung.
Deswegen ist er nicht alt geworden.
Meine Mutter ist jetzt inzwischen hoch betagt.
Ich bin nicht mehr bekannt, dass sie eine Knieatrose hat.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, wir waren eine große Familie.
Ich habe vier Geschwister.
Sind Ihre Geschwister gesund?
Ja, eine Geschwister ist schon verstorben.
Sie ist sehr früh am Herzepack gestorben.
Mein Beileiter ist mir sehr leid.
Wie alt war Ihr Geschwister, wenn sie gestorben ist?
Als sie gestorben ist, ja.
Sie war 60.
Und möchten Sie noch etwas hier so viel geben, Frau Hansen?
Ich habe Ihnen jetzt so viel erzählt, Herr Doktor,
dass ich gar nicht weiß, was ich dann noch erzählen kann.
Eigentlich haben wir glaube ich alles Wichtige besprochen.
Ich möchte nur wissen, was wir gegen die Kopfschwarze tun können.
Frau Hansen, wir sind am Ende dieser Aufnahmegespräch.
Ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen.
Meine Kollegen werden Ihnen Blutdruck messen.
Dann werde ich ein paar Labordeognostik machen
oder von Ihnen ein bisschen Blut abnehmen.
Das pickt immer, ne?
Ja, und eine Röntgen, oder?
Was soll ich machen? Ich weiß es nicht.
Die Röntgen brauchen Sie eigentlich nicht.
Ja, vielleicht Kranialpomografie oder Schädotomografie.
Aber ich soll mit meinem Oberarzt über Ihren Fall sprechen.
Dann werde ich Sie gleichzeitig informieren.
Das ist gut, ja. Alles klar.
Hier gibt es einige, bitte legen Sie sich.
Bitte?
Also ja, ich lege mich dann da jetzt hin, genau.
Hab'n Kolleginnen und Kollegen andere Fragen?
Wie Sie wissen, können ich diesen Patienten bereisen?
Ja, sehr gut, ja.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Ja, oh, Dr. Gün, das sind einige Fragen. Ja, wollen wir mal gucken?
Haben Sie Ihre Wasserlassen und ungewöhnliches Geruch?
Nein, nicht Geruch.
Geruch?
Geruch oder Mundgeruch, vielleicht bemerkt.
Also wo habe ich jetzt Geruch bemerkt? Mundgeruch oder Geruch beim Wasserlassen?
Beides. Beides.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie regelmäßig Ihre Brutzucker kontrollieren?
Na ja, der war bisher ja nicht so spannend.
Ich kontrolliere ihn nicht, bis ich die hin und wieder mal zum Hausarzt.
Und dann kriege ich mein neues mit Formin verschrieben.
Aber jetzt in letzter Zeit bin ich länger nicht zur Kontrolle gewesen.
Nur ist, wann genau haben Sie, wo denn Ihre Diabetes...
Vielleicht vor drei Monaten?
Drei Monate.
Da war so viel zu tun bei uns in der Arbeit, ne?
Und hier Blutdruck, Bluthochdruck, haben Sie haben gesagt.
Und heute, Ziahoch, normalerweise, hier Blutdruck, Welche Parameter, Messer...
Ich habe die Frage nicht richtig verstanden.
Können Sie bitte noch einmal wiederholen?
Ich habe Ihnen gesagt, heute Ihre...
Boah, Blutdruck, ja.
180 zu 90.
Ja?
Normalerweise haben Sie Welche...
Beiden Sie, welche Werten ich normalerweise habe?
Normalerweise Welche Welche haben Sie?
Ach so, ja.
Ich habe ein schlechtes Akustikempfang gerade.
Schlechtes Akustikempfang.
Ich habe es aber jetzt verstanden.
Normalerweise ist er so zwischen Mitte-Ramiprile, mit 130, 140 zu 80.
Und dann war er eben vor drei Tagen bei 150
und heute Morgen eben so hoch.
Das war es.
Das war es, gut.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Eine, haben Sie doppelsehnen?
Ja, nee, das hat er ja gefragt, ob ich Doppelwilde habe oder Blitze.
Ich habe nur einen Flimmern vor den Augen.
Also stellen Sie sich vor, wie früher ein alter Fernseher,
als wir Kinder waren.
Ein schlechter Fernseher, wo das Bild so flackert,
so muss man sich das vorstellen.
Sie haben gesagt, Ohren soll sie oder Ohren gehorchen?
Welche?
Ohren gehorchen habe ich gar nicht drüber gesprochen.
Ohren soll sie haben sie?
Nein, habe ich nicht gesagt.
Oh, keine Hörstörung.
Keine Hörstörung, nur eine Augenstörung.
Also Flimmern vor den Augen.
Keine Hörstörung.
Über Gehör haben wir gar nicht gesprochen.
Keine Hörprobleme.
Ohren soll sie haben sie?
Nein, Ohrensausen habe ich nicht.
Haben sie sich irgendwo eher an den Kopf angeschlagen?
Oh, das ist auch eine interessante Frage.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Also auch kein Unfallereignis oder so etwas.
Können wir als das Geschenk der Erkang werden?
Ja, ich habe es geschrieben.
Hallo Frau Doktor.
Schönen guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend Ihnen auch.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten um Ihnen vorzustellen.
Ja bitte.
Wie haben Sie gesehen?
Frau Hans Hansen ist drei- und sechs-jährige Patientin.
Die sie heute Abend bei uns wegen seit drei Tagen aufgetreten
und sie haben auf der anderen Seite die Kopfschmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Patientin berichtet, dass die Schmerzen sehr heftig sind
und beim Stress schlimmer geworden sind.
Hat sie gesagt, dass die Schmerzen genau lokalisiert sind?
Die beiden Seiten und die Augen, oder wie kann ich es sagen?
Temporal, bilateral.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen abends acht von zehn und morgens sechs von zehn auf der Schmerzskalasie sind.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen hätten.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen dauerhaft hätten.
Es gibt in Ruhe, da sind die Schmerzen besser geworden.
Bei der Nachtruhe gibt es morgens weniger Schmerzen an und abends mehr.
Wenn sie ihre Ruhe hat, hat sie weniger Schmerzen.
Aber immer noch heftig.
Die Frau Hansen hat einmal ihre Blutdruck gemessen,
dass die 180 zu 90.
Wann hat sie diesen Wert gemessen?
Heute Morgen.
Haben Sie schon einen neuen Blutdruckwert bestimmt?
Nein, ich werde die Teilparameter überprüfen.
Das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen früher angezeigt gewesen.
Die Patienten sind nur die Politiker aufgefallen.
Die Fragen nach Übelkeit, Erbrechung, Unmach,
wurden von den Patienten verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese sei unaufwendig.
Die Frau Hansen, als Vorerkrankungen,
leide Frau Hansen die folgenden ein, Arteriellaipatroni
und Diabetes mellitus, Tipsi White.
Sie nehmen bei Bedarf ein Ibuprofen 600 mg,
aber diese Medikamente haben sie nicht geholfen.
Sie hat eine Penicillin-Allergie und ausserzt sich mit Exantem.
Sie sei nicht Traurin und trinke gelegentlich Alkohol,
aber sie haben keine Kontakt mit Traurin.
Manchmal fahren sie an der Wochenende Fahrrad,
oder schwimmen. Sie sind verheiratet und haben zwei gesünderte Töchter
und wohnen mit ihrem Mann.
Frau Hansen ist ein Buchhalter im Tischlerreich
und die Familienanamnese ergibt sich,
die folgenden Mutter,
die Vater der Frau, die die Vater an Staublung gestorben,
und die Mutter leidet an Gonard Rose.
Sie habe vier Geschwister und vorne eine an Myokardinfarkt
mit Zechsikilebensia-Alten gestorben.
Die Anamnestchenangaben, die Anamnestchenangaben, oder meine Verdachtdiagnose die ich gehe von
Hypertension Attacke aus, aber die Differenzialdiagnose, das könnte es noch sein.
Die Differenzialdiagnose kommen die Folgenden in Betracht.
Die Patienten können nicht mit Medikamenten reinnehmen.
Deswegen ist die Bluthochdruck unkontrolliert.
Wie nennt man das?
Hypertension Krise, aber die Bluthochdruck hat noch eine andere Vorerkrankung.
Die Diabetes-Mehlitus, und ich versuche die Naher mehr.
Das ist die richtige Spur.
Also, was könnte da sein?
Sie hat Kopfschmerzen, sie trinkt wahnsinnig viel, und sie hat Stress.
Unkontrollierte Diabetes oder Zuckerkrankheiten.
Entgleist.
Ein Gleis ist das, wo der Zug draufhört.
Wenn der Zug entgleist, kann er nicht mehr weiterfahren.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Phase?
Als erster Massnahme würde ich die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Die X-Cose-Zeichen kann eine neurologische Untersuchung sein.
Was machen Sie noch?
Sie hat etwas von sehr hohen Blutdruckwerten gesagt.
Das ist die Vitalparameter.
Sie heuchten sie ab, sie messen den Blutdruck.
Worauf gucken Sie denn noch?
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Blutbild, BSC, besonders Glycos.
Was kann ich noch?
Der CRP kann sein.
Ich dachte, es ist inusitis.
Ah, wäre auch noch eine Idee.
Die Daimöer, vielleicht ein Schlaganfall?
Da hat es aber keine typischen Anzeichen.
Was haben Sie noch mit dem Diabetes?
Hämoglobin A1C.
Glycohemoglobine.
Was könnte man Labortechnisch noch untersuchen?
Bei der Ürin-Untersuchung ist die Glycose.
Wenigstens ein Schnelltest.
Ich glaube, dass es jeden Tag eine Katosis gibt.
Wir können das auch in der
Laborte untersuchen.
Was wäre noch, wenn es keine zielführenden Ergebnisse bringt?
Was könnte man für Untersuchungen machen?
Ich würde die Kranialkompetitomographie veranlassen,
wenn es keine Probleme gibt.
Wie wäre die Therapie?
Bei der hypertensiven Trise, wie wäre die Therapie?
Antiperspektive.
Geben Sie die im Schuss oder wie?
Normalerweise.
Ich war ein Hausarzt, deswegen würde ich ein Tablette geben.
Oder Tropfen, das gute Biotensin.
Man gibt es nicht schnell, sondern langsam.
Was wäre im Falle, dass die einfach über Zucker ist?
Dass der Blutzucker entgleist ist?
Es ist abhängig von der Zuckerwerte.
Wenn es nicht so sehr hoch ist,
würde es noch Infusion, Therapie, Salin geben.
Oder Insulin, wenn es höher ist.
Vielleicht auch eine dauerhaft bessere Einstellung für die Patientinnen?
Vielleicht sollten wir diese Medikamente verschreiben.
Zumindest dem Hausarzt vorschlagen.
Und andere Medikamente geben?
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich bin gespannt, wie sich die Untersuchungen herauskommen.
Wie würde man Schmerzmittel aufgeben,
nochmal höher dosiert wegen der Kopfschmerzen?
Das ist eine echte Frage.
Wir können geben, aber wenn die neurologische Untersuchung normal ist.
Nach der Untersuchung, damit das nicht verfälscht.
Ich bin gespannt auf Ihre Untersuchungsergebnisse.
Muss die Stationär bleiben?
Wenn die Untersuchung normal ist, ist das nicht möglich.
Kann sie wieder nach Hause?
Wenn der Blutzucker ganz durcheinander ist,
würde man die Verschallung aufgeben.
Dann wird die Verschallung normalisiert.
Sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.